Bitte bewegen Sie Mitglied. Ich kann Sie hier wohnen lassen.
Es tut mir leid, die Tastatur ist gleich dort.
Sie können mich in mein Gebäude füllen. Gehen Sie mir aus dem
Weg.
Okay, warten Sie, Einheit
Türwartestation Ich brauche dir das nicht zu sagen,
was weißt du, wohnst du in 307, okay,
großartig,
ich bin im vierten Stock, entschuldige, nein, du
hast keinen Schlüsselanhänger, du warst ich, du
hast das, dann okay, Ma  „Bin du nicht der
Sicherheitsdienst, du bist nicht der Hausverwalter,
du weißt, dass ich hier wohne, okay, und ich lebe auch
hier, du bist nicht Mike Herman, du bist
nicht Rick, oh, ich frage, was du möchtest, ich
muss es nicht  Sagen Sie dem
Informationsmann, wenn Sie in mein Gebäude kommen wollen,
es ist nicht Ihr Gebäude, Sie sind nicht der
Eigentümer.
Ich zeige Ihnen alles in einer Sekunde, Ma'am
in diese
nein nein oh ja
weil ich gerne wissen würde wer
befreundet ist und warum du hier bist und wenn
ja dann würde ich dich gerne kennenlernen weil
dein nachbar den ganzen weg zu  meine tür du
siehst meine schlüssel in der tür das ist so dass
[musik]
nein du weißt nur wie gute nacht gnädige frau
das mach das nie wieder
du siehst auf dem video ziemlich blöd aus ich wünsche dir eine
schöne nacht mein name ist mr.  danke